all right
before we start I was saying to Bob
right before we close the show he should
have a show on CNBC wouldn't he be great
so he'd be on it
he was so good on it he should have a
show once again right to the cheering
Bob okay all right so flying herpes at
what a name
flying herpes Neal which future is
that's you Neal which future scientific
breakthrough are you looking forward to
the most I can answer that
okay well curing old age that if you
live forever you will lose the urge to
bring intensity to your life you can
alright do it tomorrow right I wonder
how much you'd worry about that when
you're dying but in fact my life is
given that much more meaning knowing
that I'm going to die and I use that to
exploit every moment but when that
moment comes I predicted if I had a full
life I would say what Einstein said when
they said we can operate on you and
prolong your life and he said my work is
done
really yes
I'm not that good yeah meaning is
overrated right okay good
do you think the American automotive
industry will ever fully shift from
gasoline to biofuel or electric you like
electric cars yes I do because
electricity is inherently more efficient
the only problem right now is battery
technology doesn't quite give us enough
range yet you know you fill a car like
the new Tesla with a 30 or 40 thousand
dollar battery pack you can get 300
miles but that's not a real commercial
proposition but and in about five years
we'll have lithium sulfur in about ten
years we'll have lithium air then we'll
have about 10 times the energy density
of today's lithium-ion batteries and
you'll have a car with a relatively
small battery pack with every morning
after you've plugged it in you've got a
400 mile range in the car at that point
I think I think we can kiss the internal
combustion engine goodbye for cars
that's for the long commute right 400
mile Rick well but if this gives you
something that no gasoline car has which
is every morning when you when you start
you've got a fool 400 mile tank yeah but
it's gonna be a gradual transition okay
Nathan whould asks regarding Matt Taibbi
recent obituary andrew breitbart death
of a douche what level of rhetoric is
acceptable upon someone's passing and
should we respect the dead well let me
put that in perspective because I've
read many places I didn't remember this
but when Andrew Andrew when Ted Kennedy
died Andrew Breitbart wrote that day on
his Twitter that he was human excrement
so I you know just because somebody else
does something shitty doesn't mean I
would so I don't agree with that but I
didn't realize that Matt Taibbi wrote
this already this this phrase you know
people often say you know you should not
speak ill of the dead right I mean when
is a better time to speak ill of someone
than one
I mean say it's the tie if the time when
people die it's cowardice because if
they were live they'd jump up and kick
your ass do people spoke ill Angra by
power when he was alive for one thing
well then and for another thing you know
when people die
you know people assess their work and
assess their lives and come up with some
conclusions and andrew breitbart
certainly has never been restrained when
it came to offering posthumous what are
we doing judge don't we do it because of
the family well why because the family
has enough to deal with moment somebody
dies so you don't pile on but I read a
lot of in the paper today coming out on
the airplane I read a lot of you know
progressive commentary which that we
didn't agree with his views yes but he
was passionate he was a brilliant writer
he stated his case well the guy died for
you three or four kids that's different
than diner 886 and you know what I mean
it's a it's a little different but now I
know Matt like Johnny our glass adhesive
he would have said there's nothing he
said it wouldn't have said before I
probably said it to his face I mean
incorrectly you know he thought if he's
not a two-faced guy at all we have you
right in the stomach
David a yes a couple of weeks ago bill
that must be me said that today there
could not be a couple like James and
Mary Matalin I'd like to ask mr.
Carville if he agrees well yeah I guess
everything exists today
yeah but I'm what I'm saying just with
the with the kind of with the kind of
polarization we have an apology it
couldn't be today and Mary that's what I
was you know people always come up to me
time and time again every day and say
you know my wife's at the Republican I'm
a Democrat or vice versa and you see
that see that all the time I people
gonna fall in love and get married all
the time Jim people come Mary Ford
people you know
yes it's just to industry yes let's just
admit that you and Mary are a figment of
all of our imaginations go and get a
would shampoo it ain't gonna be a
figment anything that's a would all
right there was another school shooting
this week and no real conversation about
gun control that always happens in
America I'm glad I live in New York City
where it's safe
what type of tragedy will have to happen
before such a thing could take place I
don't know I'm not lips yeah I mean guns
in America is is religion yes that's
much people love their their guns much
more than their Bible they don't
actually read the Bible but they really
polish the guns and shoot I think you
tackle the Second Amendment
at your peril yes politician well that's
what the Democrats learned in 2000 when
Al Gore lost his home state of Tennessee
and they blamed it on his dead son lost
his home country United States
he lost the popular vote the United
States right and I wasn't very smart I
was still working on the wood rolling
pit I would Jim how can the candidates
make false promises on gas prices when
in fact the power resides outside of our
control well politicians cannot exercise
any control of gas prices other than
driving them up by adding more taxes
which I always say if I were emperor of
the United States which is the only
position I would accept or be qualified
for since I was born in Switzerland but
I would add 25 cents a gallon federal
tax revenue until few and that would
give people a chance to start adjust
their purchases because they're
projecting gas prices out into the
future at least there'd be some
certainty and it would drive people into
more fuel-efficient vehicles but other
than going up to say that if elected I
will make sure that gasoline goes to 250
a gallon it's patently absurd I don't
know if I'd agree with that premise that
politicians can't affect prices the
reason why the gas prices are high now
is because of Iran it's not because of
supply it's because you're talking about
a war with Iran that what but you know
it's it's always going to be the
marginal barrel somewhere in the world
and speculation and necks but you know
what drives years ago speculators only
controlled 30% of the market now they
control 80% of the market that's a big
difference
Rex tells them the CEO of Exxon says he
says that speculation is 30% I don't
know I don't know but if he says 30 you
can get that's a 30 even even if it is
30 that's enough to put upward price
pressures on the thing but the original
question was I think can politicians
affect make a promise to say if elected
I will make sure that gasoline prices go
down I think that is the most
unfulfillable promise that any
politician could make there's a lot of
competition for that - you will address
it on your new CNBC show all right thank
you everybody we gotta go
ask bill and its guests to have
questions right after the show at
hbo.com